tapie contre le pen et nous allons bien
voir qui va gagner à une bonne nuit
c'est pas tripoter la braguette par des
gamins - artix mais qui a laissé là vous
échouez depuis 40 ans et ça fait 40 ans
j'ai devant moi
[Musique]
vous êtes un hâbleur
il ya notamment vous êtes un tartarin à
bloc et je vous écraserait monsieur
tapie a marseille c'est pas parce que
vous avez une grande gueule et vous
crier fort que vous arrivez au livre on
le sait la différence la seule
différence c'est que c'est pas parce que
vous affirmez fort quelque chose que ce
que vous dites est vrai parce que vous
dites n'importe quoi voir et et l'utopie
à n'ont sûrement pas au genre surtout
pas parce que si on arrête utopie à la
fin on se retrouve qu'avec des le pen
dans le monde
c'est le produit compte des nombreuses
erreurs que vous avez pu commettre
change pas dans la lutte armée
il faudrait dire à quelqu'un que vous
connaissez de très près jean-marie le
pen nuit il a gagné ses procès c'est que
lorsque on l'a et moi j'ai pas vu quand
on vous a accusé de pédophilie vous
n'avez pas gagné vos procès même à une
bonne nuit c'est pas tripoter la
braguette par des gamins mois la la la
la
le père de ma mère était étranger lui
même est ce que ça suffit pour avoir le
droit du sang monsieur le pen ou être
français par naissance il faut avoir un
des deux parents français
il masque histoire monsieur sarkozy a
dit si je ne réussis pas eh bien je m'en
irai eh bien je crois que vous allez
être obligé de bien vous voyez c'est une
nouvelle différence entre vous et moi
vous vous échouez depuis 40 ans et ça
fait 40 ans que justement il souffre
beaucoup monsieur mélenchon notamment un
des critiques qui sont faites aux
politiques et pourtant qu'est ce que
vous les méritez un parce que qui a
contribué à faire croire aux français
que l'intégralité des hommes politiques
étaient malhonnêtes c'est vous et c'est
vous parce que vous parce que parce que
mais oui bien sûr marty mais qui a les
soldats